Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192.
David P Here's a very interesting voicemail.
Now, I have spoken about this in the past.
I've spoken before about a so-called incel
component to some of the mass shootings.
Okay.
Some here's a caller who is picking up on
something that may be true.
I'm going to play it for you and then I want
to get your thoughts.
Listen to this.
Speaker 5: Hey, David Logan here.
I was just curious about your opinion on something.
So it seems like most of the shooters that
go around and shoot up schools are mostly
sexually frustrated, bullied young individuals.
Do you think if prostitution was legalized
in America and certain individuals could have
access to certain kinds of things, do you
think that might have an impact on reducing
the amount of shootings in America?
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, the question is.
If the shooters were having sex, would they
not be shooters that they at the fundamental
core of the question.
It's that question would having I mean, really,
it's even more than that.
Right?
It's not just inability to find.
Typically the shooters are heterosexual males,
so I'll use the term girlfriend, although
we could be talking about a partner significant
other.
Generally speaking, it does seem as though
a lot of these shooters are not establishing
romantic relationships in what might be a
typical way given their ages.
And so the question fundamentally is if they
had a girlfriend or if they just had more
social connections, would it probably reduce
the number of shootings?
I think the answer is it very well might.
But what do you do about that?
And regardless, should people who, if they
can't find a girlfriend, are going to shoot
up a school, have access to guns like it doesn't
change the gun situation.
But I think it's completely fair and really
it's responsible to say this is such a complicated
and major issue.
I talk about gun safety, but we shouldn't
only be talking about guns.
We you know, when the right says, well, we've
got to deal with mental health, yeah, let's
deal with it.
So you Republicans should stop voting against
bills to better fund access to mental health
care.
Let's increase access to mental health care
in the country.
But let's also require a psych eval for having
a gun.
So maybe we can identify more people who should
be directed instead of to getting a handgun
or a rifle to a therapist of some kind.
Let's do all of the above.
Should we consider?
You know, not this whole eliminate all doors,
but does it make sense to have police do evaluations
of schools and say, here's five recommendations
that could be done to increase security, do
it, of course, do all those things.
But the guns have to be a part of it.
And additionally, this element of, well, what
is the connection between lack of social connection,
lack of romantic relationships and people
doing these things?
Let's explore it anecdotally.
It does seem as though there's this is a correlation
factor, although the causation is much more
difficult to ascertain.
Ascertain.
So interesting voicemail.
Many of you have emailed in about essentially
the same issue.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Joe Biden is pointing to an assault weapons
ban as a, quote, rational option for gun control
and gun safety.
We're going to discuss it on the bonus show.
Number two, we have never been great at recycling
plastic.
And there are states trying a new approach,
which we're going to discuss on today's bonus
show.
And in addition, the manager of the San Francisco
Giants is taking a break from his anthem protest
because of Memorial Day.
We're going to talk about that.
We're going to talk about what he's been doing,
Gabe Kapler, and see what people think.
And much more when I am joined by producer
Pat on today's bonus show.
You can get access to the bonus show by signing
up at join Pacman dot com.
Alex Jones doesn't want you to do this.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Alex Jones, in fact, in fact, finds everything
I do predatory.
Speaker 4: That is a frickin predator.
Speaker 1: He doesn't like me, but I recommend
signing up at join pacman dot com and you
can use the coupon code.
Big voting 22 to get a sizable discount.
I will see you on the bonus show in a moment.
Or otherwise, back on tomorrow's program.